we know you've put your own money into
one BR and now you've said I believe
that you feel confident you can raise
what four to five million for another
picture of someone else's money
what gives you that confidence how do
you know that I mean you you took this
chance you and and the writer director
put your own money in first uh the thing
gives me confidence is awareness
um we know
with confidence we can I can tell you
that as of right now before going on
these Ava platforms you probably had
roughly 100 million people have watched
this film I can't tell you why I know
that but I can tell you there's a
mixture of Nielsen has a Tracker and
some other aspects that we have uh were
privy to
um it's it's interesting to
you know have
the confidence based off of numbers that
we think that you know about there's
certainty 100 uh that we know if that
many people have watched you if 100
million people watched your movie and
this is before it goes on avod right
another 50 60 million people could watch
it then there's 330 million people
United States right
do you think we can convince a million
people to come see this movie
theatrically the next movie theatrically
I think the answer is yes I think not
only a million you could probably
convince two million people so 20
million dollars in the lifespan of a
movie in a theatrical release context
right well 50 is going to the theater
and if you have to have a theatrical
distribute another 20 is gone so you're
making about 30 of like either this 10
million or even this like uh 20 million
let's say
well if it's if it's uh if it's 20
you've already made your money back
right there Plus numbers 20 for your
investors and stuff
um we're not even counting like a
Netflix deal or a you know in terms of
an S5 uh deal and a t-vod uh that window
too if you have a hundred million people
have watched your film your t-vod should
be two to three million dollars it could
be just that if not more
um then like I said the asphalt release
then go to avod what's that going to do
for you and in addition to that
people are going to go back and watch
the first movie twos that'll make money
as well
if you plan like a Trilogy right and at
least the second one does the numbers
like we're talking about third one will
absolutely do the same numbers if not
just as much if it's a good movie look
it could be a piece of crap but at least
I'll do half of that right
um you know we've already read the
script the script's actually better than
the first one
um if the first one's alien the second
one's aliens so we really do feel like
we're offering uh like the film go or
something like a bigger Universe a
bigger sort of like continuation of the
story you know it really does uh you
know have a much bigger scope and I feel
like given the awareness and given how
many people watch the film we will not
only make people's money back but we'll
make them some money so I feel very
confident about this this time you know
in fact I'm trying to like scrape up as
much like money as I can myself to put
it in just myself because I'd rather
just like have some ownership uh you
know the film entrepreneurship that
people talk about right it's good to
have a piece of uh what you have if it's
considered successful I mean it's an
interesting thing with the first one
like look
this is money that if we have a second
and third movie I'll make passive income
on this movie the rest of my life I mean
hopefully knock on wood if you have one
successful project it can be successful
uh for a long time to come if you if
you've marketed it correctly there's
awareness is there so awareness that's
the main thing awareness is key
awareness is key and the same
screenwriter same writer director uh
he's our he's our brother he's our
partner
um we I don't know that we could do with
anybody else other than him I mean only
only way we wouldn't is if you got too
big for it and just wants to go out and
do other more interesting projects and
this and that but uh but no we would
love for him to be involved with all
this stuff
I don't know how much you can talk about
uh the second one so it's 2BR right uh
it's it's not called TBR uh people would
tell you people seem to think that's the
idea let me tell you why it's not called
tbrs all right so when you go on to like
I don't know peacock for example and you
go in their horror section well it's all
alphabetical but what becomes before the
alphabet the numbers come before the
alphabet right so when you come on to
Peacock for example you'll see we're on
the first very first page you come up
one br
now wouldn't it be smarter to call it
1vr colon something so that you retain
that spot and you just call it something
different right so that's why you know
2BR is not as good an idea sure so but
we can't say what it's called okay no
problem
it's one br colon and then whatever it
else at least then the
together if if the first one's still on
the platform so now that people go oh
wait a minute well they're right next to
each other right
so that makes sense yeah that makes
sense yeah so you know it's funny too
though that uh
the you would think that
um you know people always wanna the 2BR
thing and like she's just moving on to a
two bedroom that's it that's Mo that's
Olympic that's the other joke that we
make tourism through like uh we got two
bedrooms not moving to a bigger place
right well maybe she's gonna have single
white female
roommate
was it your plan to turn 1br into a
sequel or a series of movies all along
um well we
I had a discussion like what happened
was this I thought it could definitely
be a sequel but in terms of the couple
endings we shot it might have been or
might not have been
and producers were pushing very
much towards the the ending that we have
right now where it definitely lends
itself to you know a sequel and stuff
like that because we felt like
um there was more to tell and we could
cleverly I mean look I couldn't thought
they could make a sequel out of Die Hard
and like we have like six movies so we
knew there was always a way to do it
um but you know and and the ending we
have is a real there at the end or is it
kind of ending which we thought was kind
of cool too so that helped us really
cement the idea that we were going to
have the sequel like it was talked about
but then I was like no no that ending
will make sure that we people want to
see what happens next
so yes it came down to the ending we
picked and we already had ideas for it
anyways but the ending really helped us
a minute what are your biggest concerns
making 1br into a franchise going
forward
well I mean there's a believability to
it you know some people talk to
Nashville why we didn't want to do a TV
show
I really feel like it's it lends itself
in terms of believability to these sort
of episodic like not episodic but like
these these two hour hour and a half
like uh next chapters let's say I feel
like to stretch into TV show there's
times people start questioning the
reality of it it's it's almost it's hard
enough to get them to suspend their
disbelief but I feel like we can do that
in movie sized chunks versus like
episodic kind of things where it's
Seasons or something like that that
doesn't make sense to me I think it's
more of a movie
on the producing side is there anything
that you aim to do better this time
around well you know we know quite a lot
I mean we learned a lot
um you know
we definitely
understand what the distribution game is
I think that just I mean we have a very
honest distributor uh dark sky
um you know and and they're a
mom-and-pop they're Boutique they helped
us quite a lot
um you know I feel like we did a lot of
the marketing in comparison to what they
did so I feel like you know the next
time we go do this you know maybe we
need someone who's not gonna you know I
don't know if we could still work with
them again or whatever it is but I think
that Having learned what we learned I
think that we can do a lot of the stuff
ourselves I think that we should um
try to distribute globally more
ourselves rather than handle
sub-distributors unless you're gonna
have a theatrical opening and you need
that relationship that they have the
local distributor has with the theater
chain let's say that's probably the only
reason when you want to have someone
that you have to sub distribute to
um but I think we've learned a lot in
terms of that part of the business I
think we've made a lot of relationships
with actual
um like journalists and Horror in the
horror Community
um I still have a public I would still
do a publicist all day long but I think
that there's a lot of opportunities for
us to go directly to you know certain
journalists and sales and we have
relationship we would love to sit down
with you and like we would bring you
these people and and do that more so and
keep that sort of Grassroots thing up
um where you know they I think that it's
really great when you have a
relationship with somebody in general
whether it be a journalist or anybody
let's say that you continue the
relationship right
um especially if they're supportive of
your work then you want to give them
sort of like I'm going to give you the
first dibs on this you know Screw the LA
Times Like Trend Central gets it or
whatever it is you know you want to
Foster and support that relationship
um and you know hopefully you guys are
both going to be here a long time so
this isn't just the only movie you're
bringing them you're bringing them other
things too you know but I think that
it's important into
continue and Foster a Grassroots kind of
spirit to the whole thing and no matter
how big it gets people like discoveries
they like discovering like horror movies
and the horror Community is very
passionate about it they get they get to
the point where they'll tell like 10 of
their friends like it's amazing how how
verbal and how the word of mouth in a
horror Community travel so much more
than even like a regular you know not a
romantic comedy or whatever it is right